soleil brillant et cadre prestigieux
pour le baptême de l'azantia la dernière
née de Citroën première caractéristique
c'est une voiture bretonne montée dans
les usines renaises c'est aussi un
véhicule maison qui emprunte son avant à
la XM et qui porte bien la griffe de la
marque quant à sa ligne générale le
constructeur espère en Valais rapidement
les fidèles mais aussi ramener tous ceux
qui se sont laissés séduire ces
dernières années par les belles
étrangères en privilégiant dès la sortie
les modèles haut de gamme
aujourd'hui trois versions sont
proposées pour une fourchette de prix
allant de 99000 à 165 000 francs
l'habitacle la finition confère aussi à
cette nouvelle auto une qualité de
conduite agréable mais surtout s'en
tiens porte sur le plan économique tous
les espoirs de Citroën qui de plan
sociaux en licenciement espèrent
retrouver son second souffle avec ce
modèle actuellement l'usine de la
Jeannette qui a déjà construit 10000
Xantia produit 400 véhicules par jour un
chiffre qui sera porté à 600 à la fin
mars et dès juillet les chaînes pourront
sortir 1000 entiers par jour
[Musique]